michael davies joining us here from the
men in Blazers on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Michael hey rich I can't
believe you're making me miss Iran Spain
for there's so much missing for this
well I'm watching you're so rich every
but the whole nation a grit by the mill
little drawer going on right now
Iran insane well Spain's on edge right
now would you not say Michael would you
say well yeah maybe I mean this is a you
know as he saw Belgium held scoreless in
the first half we will see we will see
yes Spain would would like a result
against Iran they might expect it well I
know you can also multitask you do that
for a living so you can have this chat
while watching that nil-nil game in the
31st minute is we're chatting right now
yeah why not be distracted I don't have
a TV in front of me I'm not watching
anything okay well I'll give you an
update if they score I'll just burst
right in in the middle of all this what
do you think is the story of the World
Cup so far like well the story of the
World Cup so far I mean I think far to a
certain extent the video assistant
referee in the story of the World Cup is
the star that nobody knows we're
actually seeing some sensible calls made
by refs
in this World Cup and a couple of missed
calls there are a few teething problems
but var is really making a massive
massive impact and I think some of the
big players and I think there was a
moment in that opening round Cristiano
Ronaldo that free-kick against Spain
right at the end just he has announced
himself as the goat he's even grown a
little beard to prove it and he scored
he scored his fourth goal of the
tournament to get Portugal three points
and which again is what puts a little
bit of pressure on Spain here today
needing a result to use your phrase very
it was still very early rich this is
sorry we can all get overexcited it's
still very early in the scheme of a
World Cup and I think we're going to see
we've almost had a surplus of narrative
with the host nation Russia doing so
well so many headed goals like a
ridiculous number of headed goals
ridiculous number of goals and set
pieces this ball that flies through the
air had almost rocket like speed it's
been very good so far it's been very
good football well I mean and then the
header from Harry Kane in the 91st
minute the other the other night
yeah it's Tunisia
can came run for office do you think
right now anything that doesn't need to
run for office we've still got a House
of Lords he could probably be invited
into the monarchy at this point I think
the ratings for that game in Britain
dwarfs the ratings for the Royal Wedding
their top he led him at Megan Markell at
this point I just move into the palace
the scenes of the the exhale went that
he provided I guess because you know one
point wouldn't have been the end of the
world as you'd like to say it as you
were saying it early fine
it would have been fine but mentally
nine mentally though are mentally
obviously that wind makes a massive
massive difference a goal you know Harry
Kane always there in the right place I
mean how they're leaving him I marked in
the box it just is it's staggering a
great goal a better finish than it
looked harder goal to go and score and
this young England seen this team of
babies rich this this literal team of
babies are holding the hopes of the
nation on their backs I love the scenes
I don't if you saw them when they cut
the scenes in London at the viewing
parties of people going in a name oh
yeah and the first thing Raj and I
looked at each other immediately and
said wow there's gonna be some
unattractive babies conceived of England
tonight back in ten months right really
after absolutely attractive children I
for a close together here's all over
their head
michael davies of men in Blazers along
with Roger Bennett he's here on the Rich
Eisen show Muller saying that Germany
misjudged the situation against Mexico
what do you think he meant by by that
Michael it reminds me of the being a
manager in 1990 when asked after they
drew an opening round game against
Cameroon they are seeing the manager if
they'd underestimated camera and he goes
no we didn't underestimate them we just
didn't realize how good they were gonna
be and I think I think the Mexico took
Germany by storm I think they came out
early I think they got them on the back
so that the Germans are not used to
being in on the on the back football not
in budget in about 63 years rich 73
years at this point but it's a they they
that they struggle to deal with the
Mexican energy and aggression and for me
other than Ronaldo the best
performance in this World Cup so far has
been what Mexico did against the world
champions the develop Meister Germany so
today we were discussing this off air
and I'd like to bring it on here right
now with you Michael is that parody was
the word that you use with me when we
were talking the other day I mean is
this is this wide open is this really
like anybody could take this tournament
right now it's very wide open look at
what happened to Argentina in the first
round look what happened it was still in
the first round you know both those
teams tied Germany lost these are the
three favorites going into the
tournament France maybe they you know a
very very very late goal deflected goal
and also beat the Socceroos
so I think we got a lot of parity that
the elite teams aren't as good as that
next level of teams but I'm so much
better than the next level teams or the
next level of things I'm so much better
than some of the minnows even Saudi
Arabia who would like humiliated in the
opening game in Russia came back played
Uruguay pretty close today and would you
say it's fair that Suarez knocked out
Liverpool and Egypt essentially with one
fell swoop and Kiev in the Champions
League final a few weeks ago
well Ramos you mean yeah Ramos did it I
think with around Mostafa to the ground
that was Aramis burrata has posited that
he is a he's sort of part of a sleeper
cell Russian KGB agency and the grandmas
was actually probably born in in I don't
know somewhere deep in in Siberia and
was sort of transported to to Spain as a
child in order to in German Sallah in
complete anticipation of a rogue nation
2018 World Cup right I misspoke so you
could say that though right I mean that
that that that moment took Egypt out
essentially right yeah these it's rather
like Portugal was Ronaldo Egypt almost
Salah and we've been robbed of a player
who should have been one of the huge
stars of this World Cup and then you've
been on tour right yet the tour that you
were promoting here with Roger how's
that Torben yeah it's been pretty good
we just did the West Coast Swing which
also involved a very weird trip to st.
Louis as part of the West Coast Swing
like the Gateway to the West but st.
Louis a podcast at the airport in
Minneapolis that was sort of a highlight
and then Seattle Portland San Francisco
LA it's been great but I tell you did
couple things occurred to be honest one
if you go to any Amer
second city now and you and you make
mention of another American city but
booze that rain down the the file that
is spewed from the audience I think
there is a lot of intercity hatred
hatred in America and that bodes very
well for the future of American soccer
because I think intercity hatred is a
very important thing even in these
United States of America we've also been
talking a lot about and we had Billy
Beane on the show in San Francisco we
saw with Billy Beane about whether
American soccer rich is just to middle
class and if it's fair to expect the
best middle class kids in America to
travel around the world and to beat the
best working-class kids from every other
nation because if there was a middle
class World Cup America would win it
going away no one would be a middle
classes we have the best middle class
players in the world do you think there
are snots because we were talking about
last hour michael michael davies a
couple of minutes with michael davies of
men and blazers that there's a kind of a
soccer snob here in the United States
that doesn't like folks like me or Chris
Brock when you met a couple of weeks ago
here over here on the set surfing in
just parachuting in once every four
years to pay attention you think that's
existing I mean there are all sorts of
soccer elitist just as there are
basketball elitists and football
elitists and believe me the Gulf elitist
came out you know in in in force last
weekend after Shinnecock yeah there are
fuc elitist but there are people who
dislike the casual affair and there are
people who dislike the fan of European
soccer there are people who dislike
people like the MLS there are people who
dislike the people who dislike the
dislikes people and it's just you know I
sort of feel like anybody who's
interested in soccer any time in any
team in any form is like a rising tide
lifts all boats and it would be good for
everybody just to enjoy all of it
football should be fun
this is why I love Telemundo's coverage
with all great respect our friends at
Fox kept watching the World Cup on
Telemundo rich is one of the great great
joyous experiences of life you don't
even have to like a sport you don't have
to speak Spanish you don't have to like
football to enjoy watching football on
Telemundo
I need to do that then I gotta do that I
gotta check it out so you know that the
Spain Portugal game which ended through
three on english-language television
ended by nine on
before I let you go Michael because the
US was out we are the three of us here
on our show
pulled names out of a hat to adopt as
our adopted nation Chris Chris chose
Argentina he pulled Argentina my man
Mike chose Japan and I chose Mexico
which was phenomenal when I started
rooting for Mexico on Twitter and people
were throwing the words Wells Fargo and
Landon Donovan at me I don't know I'd no
idea why I to look it up yeah who do you
think does have the advantage when it's
all so hot Wow I think Mexico I think
you probably in Mexico but Mike with
Japan Japan are in that upside-down
group Group H where the where Japan with
that win over Columbia heartbreaking
loss for Columbia and after Poland lost
also Japan are in pretty good shape as
well I think the Mexico have a chance of
growing fairly deep in this tournament
of that'd be great
that would be great because we have a
last longer the the - who doesn't last
longest has to dress in full 48 and
regalia the water fantastic well I gotta
tell you actually on Telemundo Mexico
have already won the World Cup the NIT
going on right now so like if you if I'm
at element oh that what you've already
won rich Michael always appreciate it
you guys were great hanging out with you
guys a few weeks ago and I look forward
to chatting again during this World Cup
chorus thank you so much that's Michael
Davies at embassy Davies the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience